more than 60 gunshot wounds were found
on jalen walker's body
after officers fired a barrage of around
90 rounds
when they make their most critical
decision
to point their firearm at another human
being and pull the trigger
they've got to be ready to
explain why they did what they did
they need to be able to articulate
what specific threats they were facing
and that goes for every round that goes
down the barrel of their gun
and they need to be held to account
the 25 year old was unarmed when he was
shot
a firearm was found in his vehicle
earlier during a car chase police
believe mr walker fired from the
driver's seat
a casing was found close by
he later fled his vehicle wearing a ski
mask police tried to stop him with
tasers then moved on to firearms
[Music]
in the city of akron protests but from
jalen walker's family a call for calm
there are no words to describe what we
just saw
but we are begging you
that family is begging you jalen is
begging you
to stay peaceful
we will get nowhere with violence and
destruction
but we will
with measured
and calm dialogue
eight officers are now on paid leave as
an investigation attempts to understand
why another unarmed black man has been
shot and killed by police joe pike sky
news